for us DJ let's go back to Wednesday
yesterday and glad to be back with you
guys James Harden showed up to practice
yesterday and the Sixers were surprised
he was away for 10 days for what the
team is calling an excuse absence but
when he arrived at practice I was told
that team officials kind of suggested
that he should stay back not travel with
the team to Milwaukee so he can go
through his workouts cuz he's been away
go through his workouts and James Harden
from what I was told inter for that as
as that as as a suggestion so he went
through practice then he ended up
showing up at the airport to board the
flight with his teammates and he was
stopped by an security official who told
him he wasn't permitted to get on board
from there Elton BR General Manager for
the Sixers and head coach Nick nurse
came approached James Harden and told
him listen we need you to stay back we
have the resources we need to track your
progress we need to track your
measurables and your speed levels cuz
you've been away for so long um and we
have all the resources back at the
facility and James was not happy about
that he he wanted to get back re
acclimated with his teammates he wanted
to be here with his guy he's really
close and he works out with um coach
Rico Hines the assistant coach of the
Sixers and Rico is on the trip here so
he felt it would be better served if he
he's with the team and so he is not here
um he left the airport yesterday without
further incident I can tell you he did
go to the facility today and got his
work in but there's another wrinkle to
this the NBA is kind of weighing in this
is from Mike Bass of the NBA he says
we're looking into the facts around
James Harden's availability tonight to
determine whether an approved reason
exists for his lack of participation and
we all know with the the new guidelines
for Star players that you know usually
if a star player is hurt for whatever
reason he still has to show up at the
arena to be present and visible for fans
but from what I've told James Harden is
not hurt so I don't know what the Sixers
going to tell the NBA I know they've
reached out to both sides um to this
point and so we'll have further
developments probably in the next coming
days on what results from that
investigation I guess hurt feelings
don't count uh as as part of an injury
or something like that and and here's my
next question how long can the Sixers
let this go before they do
something that's the million-dollar
question EJ We Know darl M who you know
that's the president of basketball
operation that's who James Harden has an
issue with we know he's going to wait
until the very last last opportunity to
where he feels like he can get the value
that he is seeking in return and so I
don't know how long he's willing to go
to go this route I know James Harden we
we know James Harden you know he's going
to say what's on his mind he's going to
do what he feels in the best interest of
him but you know he wants to be out
there he wants to be out there he wants
to get back re acclimated what I can say
is I spoke with Joel and be and this
this is a star player who rival teams
are monitoring to see where he's at
where his head is at so I asked him
about the situation
and he said look I'm here to try to
guide and lead the guys that we have
available right now he said because
ultimately I want to win I want to do
what's best for the organization and I
hope that we can get in a bet in a good
situation of where we can compete at a
championship level and I say okay now
but specifically as it pertains to James
Harden where are you at with that and he
responded that we are a better team with
James hard so hopefully things can be
resolved he said but I don't know the
future